judge Smith so you probably think and
this guy has really excellent German but
no I'm actually I'm from New York I
don't actually speak German so I didn't
know what to do the intro and shy like
doing English but then that's kind of
douchey cuz like here's this American
coming in speaking English so I didn't
want to do it in English so here's I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try giving you the
intro to today's conference entirely in
CSS this is the challenge I'm a little
bit nervous about it I studied all of
the html5 element names I studied all
the css3 property names and so here we
go intro dot CSS or if you're German
introduce a set pre 96 anyway okay cool
so first of all hi hi you all hi
everybody here is your intro I'm
basically just want to give you a
background about CSS comp I'm sorry that
is that's notthat's turn the numbers but
then the and it's a nice orange so yeah
CSS come I think you'll love it it hurts
me too don't worry but before we start
I'm just going to some filler content
here and you might find it a little bit
off-color you might find it the jokes
are somewhat opaque maybe some of the
jokes are a little bit of a stretch
speaking of the jokes I'm just gonna
list them up you know it's trying to
lighten the mood
some of them might make you a little bit
barest you know make your face red or
make you blush better known as FFF oh f5
but I am a bottomless trove of bad CSS
jokes so don't make any trouble there
they're all funny but like every tenth
joke will float just right and will be
comic gold so just bear with me if it
seems slow gold also obviously FF d700
so it's gonna give you a background of
the area
here we are in Berlin it's a conference
about style in a city that has style
Berlin has so much style its styles have
style and that just keeps repeating
forever yeah it's like just walking out
on the street just seeing people on the
street
man it is so stylish even here at
Berghain people waiting in line have
style you would say they have inline
style and because it's Germany the line
height is about 2 2 X what it usually is
where I'm where I'm from but you don't
want to use inline styles is right
that's bad you wanna use these class and
you know this is City obviously is a lot
of history it has a lot of class I
haven't seen this much class it's almost
too much class like villains almost too
classy I haven't seen this much
excessive class since I last used
moderniser about the area also we are
right next to the Berlin Wall if you I'd
know it's about 2 million pixels to your
left
it is this solid border that used to
divide Germany until 1989 when it
collapsed so it's uh it's actually kind
of hard to find you actually can't find
the Berlin Wall with CSS you're gonna
need to use JavaScript using jQuery I'm
sure you guys all know how to do this
jQuery just put a selector so you just
find an area that has sold off and you
can find the Berlin Wall it's a he's
wearing a jacket you'll you'll see it
shouldn't be hard fine
so about this address where we are right
now we are on in bleedin Strasse and
again I don't know German I'm pretty
sure that in bleedin Strasse in english
would just be a street address that is
disabled it's my guess it's a breed and
about this particular section of this
area it's Beth it is a sim back or
another but the position of this place
it is right in the centre of Berlin you
can see these beautiful white walls the
background here is white
better known as ffffff but it's actually
the
a little bit old so it's faded a little
bit it's actually more like a fa eb d 7
better nose antique white apparently
fading is perfectly natural this in a
white space perfectly normal if that
happens I don't worry about it
this is actually like a parish you can't
really tell it's not on display but this
is actually you know a religious
institution so it's not on display but
if you were here like maybe 50 years ago
it would be more of a display:none kind
of thing anyway so let's talk about this
conference it is an import from the
states CSS comp started we're gonna hear
more about that later from Nicole let's
talk about CSS cough actually hold on
let me get a little bit more specific
let's talk about CSS cough EU it's the
first of its type it's I think is far
neither the only of its type it is for
the organizers is their first conference
and I'm sure you know what that means it
is in child index one so of all the
children's like the index is one or as
some of you would say the index is one
so yeah C's economy you it's uh it's
it's not for profit right so there's no
margin they don't make any margin on
this hopefully when they're done there
will be nothing left I assume what I
hope is not the case that they actually
have extra money and they just hide it
so let's hope that that is not happening
let's talk about the list of the
speakers we have excellent speakers
they're in the top 1% of their field
they are the backgrounds are really
really badass you would all say
absolutely badass so if during while
you're listening these speakers if you
are unable to focus next we have a
selection of delicious black coffee but
I've heard unfortunately we have is your
decaf which you know if you're not a
caffeine person is bad bad but let me
give you some background on that
apparently the organizers asked them to
do decaf and all they said was nine nine
nine nine nine nine and then just know
decaf so I realized that's a lot of
background jokes in a row so I'm just
gonna turn off repeat on the background
joke sorry about that it's last one also
mention the toilet
if you need directions ask me later
and once you so if you have to drink
less coughing you have to pee after you
visit the toilet and you're empty of pee
everything for your will be fixed
everything will be alright so definitely
give that a visit I want to talk we have
this policy they mentioned it's the anti
jerk policy so I just want to give you
in the in the context of CSS what that
entails so take this pretty seriously
don't disable user selection on all
elements that's kind of douchey don't
ever every seven images don't rotate
them 180 degrees like that's pretty
douchey don't fade all the paragraphs to
zero like I can't see them after 500
seconds like don't do that that would be
a jerky thing to do and finally don't
blink all of your H ones all right so
just doesn't God just don't do that
stuff that would be a definitely fall
under the jerk policy one more point I
want to make it's a I'm sorry one point
I guess it would be a pretty important
point I want to talk about if you guys
take photos or of anything
totally totally cool but I would love if
you guys could share them you can just
you can display them online if you want
to or you could you know put them around
your block or both but it would be a
shame if after CSS Kampf
we were left with zero pics so just make
sure you share them that's all I ask and
that's about it and so without further
ado I would like to bring up our first
keynote our keynote our first speaker uh
needs very little introduction so she
will get none lady and gentleman
stubborn Ella and Nicole Sullivan
you
you